imagine growing fresh delicious food
without soil now picture doing it
without electricity this is the magic of
passive Hydroponics it's a simple yet
powerful way to grow food anywhere
regardless of power access this guide is
for everyone whether you're an Urban
Gardener with limited space and off-grid
Enthusiast or just curious about
sustainable living passive Hydroponics
has something for you we'll explore the
benefits different systems and even
share inspiring success stories get
ready to discover a world of
possibilities by the end you'll have the
knowledge to start your own passive
hydroponic garden let's dive
in passive Hydroponics is all about
Simplicity and efficiency unlike
conventional Hydroponics it doesn't rely
on pumps or electricity to circulate
nutrient-rich water this makes it
incredibly coste effective to set up and
run these systems are perfect for small
scale sustainable farming they use less
water than traditional gardening as the
water is constant recycled plus you can
say goodbye to weeding and soilborne
pests perhaps the biggest Advantage is
the low maintenance once set up passive
hydroponic systems practically run
themselves this makes them ideal for
beginners and busy individuals who still
crave the satisfaction of growing their
own
food ready to explore the world of
passive Hydroponics this fascinating
method of growing plants without soil
has been gaining popularity for its
efficiency and sustainability let's meet
the four most popular systemss that you
can easily set up at home or in a
smallscale commercial operation the
simplest of all the Katy method uses no
moving Parts it's a passive system that
doesn't require electricity or pumps
plants are suspended in a
non-circulating nutrient solution with
their Roots partially submerged this
allows them to absorb nutrients directly
from the water this system relies on
capillary action where water moves up
through the plant roots ensuring they
stay hydrated a wick draws nutrient
solution from a reservoir to the plant's
roots uring a constant supply of
moisture this method is simple and
effective for small plants ideal for
larger setups this method involves
floating plants on rafts in a
nutrient-rich solution it's perfect for
growing leafy greens and herbs airstones
provide oxygen to the roots which is
crucial for plant health and growth this
helps prevent root rot and promotes
vigorous growth this system uses a bed
of clay Pebbles to support the plants
the Pebbles provide stability and allow
for excellent drainage and ation
nutrient solution is periodically
flooded and drained providing both
moisture and oxygen this method is great
for a variety of plants including
vegetables and flowers each system has
its own advantages and is suited for
different types of plants whether you're
growing herbs vegetables or flowers
there's a hydroponic system for you
we'll explore the best crops for each
system next stay tuned to find out which
plants will thrive in your chosen
hydroponic
setup one of the joys of passive
Hydroponics is the variety of crops you
can grow here are some top performers
leafy greens like lettuce spinach
arugula and kale thrive in most passive
systems especially the Kat key method
herbs such as basil mint parsley and
cilantro add flavor to your dishes and
grow quickly in wicking systems for
medium difficulty Tomatoes can be grown
in larger passive systems like the
floating raft or clay Pebble bed
strawberries with proper support in
sunlight can flourish in a
well-maintained wicking system remember
success also depends on your local
climate and the specific setup you
choose don't be afraid to experiment and
see what works best for you
five Katy Made Easy a step-by-step setup
guide let's get our hands dirty well not
really since its Hydroponics and set up
a crackie system this method is perfect
for those who want to grow plants
without the mess of soil it's simple
efficient and highly rewarding it's the
perfect starting point for beginners
even if you've never grown a plant
before you'll find this method
straightforward and enjoyable materials
you'll need a wide mouth glass jar or
container which will serve as the
reservoir for your nutrient solution
the size of the container can vary
depending on the number of plants you
want to grow net cups to hold the plants
these cups will allow the roots to grow
through and access the nutrient solution
below growing medium like coconut coir
or rock wool which will support the
plants in the net cups you'll also need
hydroponic nutrients to feed your plants
and a pH testing kit to ensure the water
is at the right acidity level and of
course seedlings or young plants choose
plants that are well suited for
hydroponic growth such as lettuce herbs
or even strawberries steps one prepare
the nutrient solution fill your
container with water and mix in the
hydroponic nutrients according to the
instructions this solution will provide
all the essential minerals and nutrients
your plants need to thrive adjust the pH
to the appropriate level for your chosen
plants most plants prefer a pH between
5.5 and 6.5 use your pH testing kit to
check and adjust the levels as needed
two plant your seedlings gently place
your seedlings or young plants in the
net cups filled with growing medium be
careful not to damage the roots during
this process three submerge the net cups
make sure the bottom of the net cups are
submerged in the nutrient solution
allowing the roots to access the water
and nutrients they need leave an air gap
between the solution and the base of the
plant this Gap is crucial as it allows
the roots to get oxygen which is
essential for Healthy Growth four place
in a sunny location find a bright spot
for your cracki system ideally receiving
at least 6 hours of sunlight per day
this will ensure your plants get enough
light for photosynthesis sunlight is
vital for the growth and health of your
plants if natural sunlight is not
available consider using grow lights to
supplement the light requirements
precautions avoid using tap water
directly as it may contain chlorine or
other chemicals that can harm your
plants these substances can interfere
with the nutrient uptake and overall
health of your plants chlorine in
particular can be detrimental to plant
growth it's best to let tap water sit
out for 24 hours to allow the chlorine
to evaporate or use a water conditioner
to remove it use filtered or rainwater
instead these options are free from
harmful chemicals and provide a more
natural environment for your plants
monitor the nutrient solution level
regularly and top it up as needed as the
plants grow they will consume the
nutrients and water so it's important to
keep the levels consistent change the
solution entirely every 2 to 3 weeks
this helps prevent the buildup of salts
and other residues that can affect plant
Health with these steps you're well on
your way to a successful hydroponic
garden using the c key method happy
growing
six thriving Gardens tips for Passive
hydroponic success congratulations on
setting up your passive hydroponic
system here are some tips to ensure your
plants Thrive sunlight is key most
plants need at least 6 hours of direct
sunlight per day choose a location
accordingly or consider using grow
lights nutrient balance use a
highquality hydroponic nutrient solution
specifically formulated for your plant's
needs pH matters regularly check and
adjust the pH of your nutrient solution
to the optimal range for your plants air
circulation good air flow is crucial to
prevent mold and mildew ensure adequate
ventilation around your system observe
and adjust pay close attention to your
plants growth and adjust your system as
needed every environment is
unique troubleshooting time common
mistakes and solutions even with the
best intentions challenges can arise
it's important to recognize that these
issues are part of the learning process
here are some common mistakes and how to
overcome them mistake one inadequate
lighting lighting is crucial for plant
growth if your plants are leggy and pale
they need more light this is a clear
sign that they are not getting enough
light to thrive move them to a sunnier
spot or use grow lights ensure the light
source is adequate for the type of
plants you are growing mistake two
nutrient deficiencies yellowing leaves
or stunted growth can indicate a lack of
nutrients this can severely affect the
health and yield of your plants adjust
your nutrient solution or try a
different brand sometimes experimenting
with different nutrient Solutions can
make a big difference mistake 3 pH
imbalance fluctuations in PH can hinder
nutrient uptake maintaining a stable pH
is essential for optimal nutrient
absorption use a pH meter to Monitor and
adjust the solution regularly consistent
monitoring can prevent many issues
before they become serious mistake four
poor air circulation good air flow is
vital for plant Health lack of air flow
can lead to fungal problems fungal
issues can quickly spread and damage
your entire crop ensure good ventilation
around your system this can be achieved
with fans or by simply opening Windows
remember pay patience is key don't get
discouraged if things don't go perfectly
at first every mistake is an opportunity
to learn and improve with a little
observation and adjustment you'll be
harvesting fresh homegrown produce in no
time the rewards of your hard work will
be worth
[Music]
it cost comparison passive versus active
Hydroponics one of the most appealing
aspects of passive Hydroponics is its
affordability let's compare the costs of
passive and active systems passive
systems require minimal materials and
can often be built using recycled
containers they have virtually no
recurring costs Beyond replenishing
nutrients active systems involve pumps
timers and potentially grow lights
leading to higher setup costs they incur
ongoing electricity expenses as you can
see passive Hydroponics offers
significant cost savings making it an
attractive option for budget conscious
Growers inspiration grows here real life
success stories countless individuals
have embraced passive Hydroponics and
transformed their gardening experiences
here are a few few inspiring examples
Urban dwellers rooftop Oasis Sarah
living in a bustling City created a
thriving rooftop garden using the cck
key method she now enjoys fresh salads
and herbs year round reducing her
grocery bills and carbon footprint
off-grid Homestead abundance John and
Mary living off- Grid in a remote area
rely on passive Hydroponics to
supplement their food supply their
wicking system provides them with a
steady supply of leafy greens and
vegetables these stories highlight the
versatility and accessibility of passive
Hydroponics proving that anyone can
cultivate fresh food regardless of their
location or
resources take the plunge start your
hydroponic Journey passive Hydroponics
opens up a world of possibilities for
growing your own food it's affordable
sustainable and Incredibly rewarding
whether you're a seasoned Gardener or
just starting these systems offer a
simple yet effective way to connect with
nature and enjoy the fruits and
vegetables of your labor start small
experiment with different systems and
crops and don't be afraid to learn from
your mistakes the Journey of passive
Hydroponics is filled with Discovery
Delicious Rewards and a profound sense
of accomplishment what are you waiting
for dive into the world of passive
Hydroponics and start growing your own
food today don't forget to like this
video subscribe to our Channel and share
your hydroponic adventures in the
comments below